pourquoi vous avez cette fleur là oh my
châu nikos hybrid friend ou à l'abri
match il a mené avec lui un ami qu'il
aime beaucoup de best comédie française
habitante qui est un des meilleurs
comiques français avoir tout ici à
gauche un bruit de me and see you y
habitait au caire et tel exploit
hier soir à rim to my friend pierre
aguillon wire cinq bons amis vous avez
été un des premiers en france à célébrer
le talent de jerry lewis
à l'époque effectivement où il a été
découvert par les cahiers du cinéma par
la revue positif et c'est vrai que c'est
la france avec benayoun aussi c'est la
france qui a été le premier pays à
rendre hommage au talent de jerry lewis
et les autres il l'avait dit un jour
l'herbe est plus verte ailleurs ça c'est
vrai je dois dire que non c'est vrai que
quand j'ai rencontré de gérer ça a été
un bonheur indicible c'est à dire qu'au
premier jour j'ai senti quelqu'un avec
qui j'étais complètement en accord
il est venu vers moi il m'a tendu les
bras il était venu à paris pour tourner
boing boing je crois à l'époque et il a
voulu me recevoir parce qu'il avait vu
monde mes films et il m'a reçu donc dans
son hôtel et m'a tendu les bras et m'a
dit je te connais et c'est vrai qu'à cet
instant j'avais le sentiment que nous
nous connaissions depuis longtemps
beaucoup de gens m'ont dit vous êtes si
différents et moi je pense qu'on est si
proche au contraire parce que les gens
ne voient que les apparences c'est
toujours l'arbre qui cache la forêt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre fils est là aussi nous sommes
illimitées ou non de 6,6 à aussi
marraine de meilleur jeune et meilleur
avenir
anthony
[Musique]
ok oui messieurs merci merci beaucoup
très bien alors vous est né en 1926 à à
newark dans le new jersey votre père
s'appelait daniel levy tx10 dany lévis
et votre mère ça plairait rothberg alors
vos parents étaient des comédiens sur
scène dans ce qu'on appelle le bortsch
circuit tu sais quoi le mot recueillir
c'est quoi le baril à new york ce type
piper used to go fort de sa main c'est
les montagnes du catch et le nord de new
york où les gens allaient passer l'été
au men women and men ten days two weeks
voilà et et vos parents joués sur scène
dans ces endroits là deux choses
fight night aubry 1 il faisait des
choses cinq nuits par des choses cinq
jours par semaine dit elle quand vous
avez commencé sur scène vous faisiez
brodeur can you spered ar oui you
remember date
yes vous vous souvenez de ça mais ça
donne
[Applaudissements]
non
ouais
voilà ce que thierry douine chanter à
l'âge de 5 ans sur scène quand il était
l'été dans les quatre îles avec ses
parents brothers can use père d'anne
c'est-à-dire brossard est ce que tu peux
me donner un 10 10 ans quoi parce que
parce que l'airé louer dans les chemins
de fer était terminée il n'avait plus
d'argent est ce que tu peux me donner
dix ans
c'est ce que vous êtes chanter merci
merci beaucoup aux vaincus et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus